you have a nine-year-old son yes for a
Henry as he inherited the freckles and
all that yeah he is so pale and freckled
and has this very blond and has very
deep voice and he talks like this
he suddenly sounds kind of
french-canadian when I do and I don't
know why because but he really does have
a deep voice he's just realized that I
do an impression of a minute he doesn't
like it he doesn't like it no a lot of
boys wouldn't like it if their mom went
around doing an impression of the two
but I but it's awful because I think
it's cute you know the same way that our
parents think it's helpful to spit on a
hankie and clean the schmutz off our
faces well my dad's a microbiologist so
he never did that
exactly he wouldn't do that he had like
gel they put on uh Henry recently came
home there and was they he was like we
did we recorded our voices at school
today and I do have a deep voice but it
sounds higher in my head what kind of
accent does he have what is that accent
your son has you have such a beautiful
accent guys and I know if you see your
guy and you know that he's doing it for
some girl well what was he like as a
baby was he well so here's the thing I
know everybody everybody's baby isn't
beautiful and that's alright and
everyone and I would say it's people the
kind no I had a giant baby he was ten
pounds and that's big yes you tried
naturally giving birth to 10 pounds when
you don't have a corresponding down by
your apron-pocket aperture it's you
referred to the female region as the
down by your apron pocket I'll refer to
that way well an elderly member of my
family used to refer to like your lady
parts as Dina down by your apron pocket
so I thought what is the most fantastic
thing I've ever heard good yeah keeps
you firmly in the kitchen yeah yeah
but also save sticker with that thing's
for ya breaking also think of the dirty
talk they had that's so crazy so so you
gave birth and you weren't it pleased
immediately he didn't have any eyelashes
or eyebrows and he'd look like a giant
little pink and white mouse right
huge and with a really misshapen head
you know he was just but then he got
beautiful so quickly but but you weren't
one of those moms that think he looks
beautiful right away I will say our son
when he was born he's a beautiful
beautiful boy but he was born yeah but
but when he was born he came out and we
were like nah he looked like part
director Charles Durning you know he
just had look it up it's really funny uh
you know but he looked like he had a
cigar coming out of his mouth yeah that
it wasn't good it wasn't good yeah we
got really got really cute and really
he's my pal he's my favorite person to
hang out with I love him so much
well that's true he's the best it ended
nicely you made fun of his voice and you
said he was ugly but then it all works
out well
you